you guys are having too much fun with
this what Khiladi what gay guys are so
happy I have never done Pilates before
I'm not sure I don't even know what to
expect
good name Pilates who came over their
name well I think Pilates I think of
very fit supermodels like I've imagined
like Victoria's Secret I don't even know
what Pilates is it just sounds easy but
I definitely kind of feel like it's a
work up that girls do Pilates Inc told
me son I'm gonna do this while I'm
eating a sandwich I think I'm gonna suck
but I'm hoping to be surprised well I
don't think I'm very flexible at all my
stomach hits my knees all the time there
are times I can't even see my feet
maybe I stop talking this is gonna be
fun I think question mark but that's
definitely not actually it's gonna be
terrible I'm excited let's do this
hey I'm Cassie ho from the channel
Blogilates on YouTube and I am a fitness
instructor and the creator of pop
Pilates I feel so grateful every day to
be doing what I'm doing because it's not
very typical for a member of the Asian
American community my parents wanted me
to become a doctor it's not where my
passion was not where my heart was and
Pilates had always been there for me as
my rock it brings me mental health it
brings me physical health emotional
health and I just love it so much today
we're doing some pop pilates I'm really
excited to teach the guys and see how
they do and we're going to inhale two
three four exhale two three four this is
a exhale two is what it is we're the
left keep going
and it helps you not a good we're get
those lower abs oh yeah three and two
and one knees in the chest head down oh
good can we make this harder else
they're gonna get injured
okay so extend the leg up lift your head
neck and shoulders just into that pot
easy out good now you're gonna pull it
in switch pull it in
he's called your single straight leg
stretch so pull it in together now
beautiful nice Ryan thank you good Ryan
was definitely an overachiever and he's
wearing his like little leggings he was
like so good and so ready now get ready
you want it harder
no guys stay right there yeah so much
[Music]
good y'all know that was better than sex
though good you're doing sex wrong
[Music]
trying hard they did great we're gonna
do something called cha-cha abs hands up
now we're gonna slightly lean back now
you're gonna bring one shoulder down
okay one shoulder down it's a
cha-cha-cha like a day yes yes now go
lower guys and I feel everything over
here well very good this is hard enough
for you yet yeah yeah get up there do it
again come on okay you're gonna
transition to something else they're
gonna make an earthquake habit in your
body I do that every time I what's the
better I make the bigger make this even
bigger rolling back my personal favorite
move is the earthquake it literally
looks like you're sitting there and then
you just start shaking like crazy
because your abs just cannot handle it
lift it one arm all right literally
already huh guys do so good
welcome your other
barre3 okay I'm done I brought the game
in I was I kept motivating the guys now
it's like yo let's go harder she went
harder it's gotta y'all got motivated
and you know what we gotta go work out
it all because of me
if I had to say someone was the worst I
definitely say gotta yell he kept
pushing for more he wanted us to do way
more stuff and I was just like no we're
already doing enough and then we would
do it he was like koala to the ground
Ryan which is Kissin ass the whole time
so I'm sorry guys yeah this is your
fault I can't do this my body's not
built for these things I got a lot of
cool old muscles the minute I put my leg
back down I could feel the pressure on
my ass she can have a yeah it's working
Pilates ain't that easy that was way
harder than I thought I was gonna be
like when I thought of Pilates I was
like oh this would be like a light
workout I was sweating more than anyone
in the class so apparently I was doing
something right how did the best of
course I did the best I feel like I have
worked out for a week and it's been like
30 minutes
that was tough and I recommend anybody
do it though I'm Adi Oh
[Music]